Scot dicklick Disick died sick he looks
like an awful person am i audible am i
audible that's all that matters
hello I'm Jeremy Clarkson I'm gonna do
arranging your ride first of all I need
to put my specs on so I can see what's
what we're gonna begin with this chap
Jack Deborah what Jack's done is he's
plunked some side skirts down the side
of his Mercedes this is unwise because
Mercedes employ some really very very
talented stylists who spent many many
years studying the art of styling and
then you come along in that jumper Luke
Davis you have a mini why we sent a
picture of this Dan Matthews he then for
The Inbetweeners look and you've even
got a another play that says p25 say and
what you're hoping is that we'll all
think it says per se but it doesn't it
says CC isn't the same he said [ __ ]
that would work Brad Clegg what are you
wearing man
Katie Price she was really pretty that's
all I'm gonna say Oliver are you wearing
a dress he has what looks like I must
Annette and Ellen a Mustang which is a
tremendous car about you clothing Oliver
I wouldn't team the dress of the shoes
but you know we live in modern times I
work for Amazon it shows transgender I'm
aware that there is now BLT and not BLT
at the sandwich Scott dicklick Disick
died sick sucking all four person I
think I've heard of him in the Daily
Mail sidebar of shame what he's saying
there is I've got a lot of money in the
hope that they'd gone this woman will
find him attractive so there we are I
thought I'd rated all you rides and I'm
just gonna look at the search engine
history very strong is strong
always funny
[Music]